[Music]
anna is in st louis hi anna welcome to
the ramsay show
anna hello hello hi how are you
i'm doing well how are you dave good how
can i help
so i never have a question regarding um
so my husband and i are in baby step 3b
and my husband works in
commission-based jobs so we don't have
any
credit score so in order for us to get
underwritten for a home loan we have to
wait two years so we're gonna have to
wait two years to get a
home loan
to qualify for a home with churchill
mortgage
a couple of days ago my father-in-law
and my mother-in-law who were in baby
step seven
offered to purchase a house and get
and let us rent to own it from them and
they have been
thinking about it and wondering what if
that's a good idea or uh
if that's something that's better not to
just
not worry about
yeah
how old are you guys
uh 27-28 and what's your household
income
about 3 000
3 000 a month
okay
um
what does your husband do
he's a plumber okay that's good news
okay
and has his income been going up
good he's still on an apprenticeship
yeah when will he finish that
uh i think he can get his journeyman
after four years
this is the kind of deal that makes
sense mathematically and is a
relational
minefield
if you miss a payment
you might go sideways
and have a weird thanksgiving dinner
as a matter of fact you might really
have a high potential for a weird
thanksgiving dinner
um
and so i uh i tell parents not to loan
their kids money
grown kids
and um and i tell people not to let me
tell you the borrower is slave to the
lender
and when you eat thanksgiving dinner
with your master
the turkey tastes different
and so i would tell you not to do this
on that basis instead use that two years
to save money
and get your income stabilized and get
his income up
i think your in-laws are not bad people
i think they're very generous they're
being kind they're trying to be trying
to get their grandbaby that i hear in
the background into a house i appreciate
that out of them and they're probably
not bad people they're probably not
toxic and controlling or something like
that or you wouldn't be considering this
but
um i i just am not i don't want you to
be susceptible to that i tell people not
to do this because i've seen more of it
go sideways than not what are you
thinking john i'm thinking
under no circumstances whatsoever should
you do this and i wasn't even thinking
about thanksgiving i was thinking about
that little baby you're holding and when
mother-in-law says well you know you
should be
that's a lot different when she owns
your mortgage
and suddenly that baby's got two moms
two dads
and can i be honest with you
absolutely it sounds like you knew the
answer colin i could hear your voice
does your husband want to do this and
you don't
i we're
i think you're right i think we kind of
knew we'd listen to
dave and dr d a lot so we kind of
knew the answer but needed someone to
tell us the answer
yeah i i i'm a thousand percent with
dave your autonomy here y'all are
grinding it he's working hard you're
working hard you're young you've got
time yeah get an apartment get a
two-bedroom apartment and y'all make it
work for the next two years and save
save save save save
and um every
yeah it sounds so good mathematically
dave's right but it's not a good move
yeah i i just
the the problem is of 30 years of doing
this i've seen
i'm like a cancer doctor i see what
causes cancer yeah you know and it's
like you know you can do that if you
want but a lot of people i've seen with
cancer had that you know it's like that
kind of a thing right and so that that's
kind of what this falls into can you get
away with it yeah you can get away with
it um i remember when we went broke uh
sharon's dad
uh went to the bank and got a loan as if
he didn't have the money in a coffee can
in the backyard probably but um and
to help us save the house out of
bankruptcy and so we owed him some money
um
and had to pay the payments to pay that
loan off after bankruptcy
and um he is
one of the sweetest kindest men
i've ever known
he is just a great guy
and he never said
didn't even wrinkle an eyebrow
never one little bit of voice inflection
nothing never said a negative word one
time but i man my butt was on fire yeah
i was driving me nuts of course i just
gone broke too so that's added to it
right but um but i'm like this is
killing me i can't i walked in this
house i felt different
it was just weird well that's that's the
thing if you don't acknowledge that yeah
that's just then you're just dumb you
can't calculate what those oh is that
the is that the shirt he's wearing to
church sounds different when she owns
your mortgage yeah or hey
y'all are only gonna stay for two days
for christmas sounds different when he
owns your mortgage it's just everything
it's like a domino of emotions and
feelings and all that stuff yeah it it
and
it's bad enough when you got a brand new
baby
there's all that's there anyway right
but then on top of that
you know let's just go ahead and put in
there
that they
but it's so tempting and i you said it
best dave those parents are they are
loving those kids that's why they know
how i got nothing in her conversation
that said they were that they're
all three but they're off the rails